Grazie, buongiorno a tutti.
Mi spiace per l'orario un po' insolito e la levataccia di domenica, ma quest'anno è andata così.
Allora, ieri abbiamo raccontato com'è che è stata presa dalle massime autorità politiche italiane la decisione di entrare in guerra il 24 maggio del 1915.
Oggi racconteremo quella che è stata la battaglia più importante da un certo punto di vista di tutta la guerra,
è certamente comunque la più famosa, la più ricordata, è che per un paradosso tipicamente italiano all'interno di una guerra che poi alla fine abbiamo vinto è però una battaglia perduta, caporetto.
In realtà poi in enorme sintesi accennerò a tutto l'andamento della nostra guerra fino a quel momento,
perché per capire una battaglia bisogna sapere in che contesto si colloca.
Una battaglia è come un momento di un lungo discorso, una guerra è un lungo discorso, combatti, ribatti,
e la battaglia è una battuta, è un momento, ha un senso dentro un andamento più generale.
E il senso di Caporetto è che va in contraddizione con tutto quello che era stata la nostra prima guerra mondiale fino a quel momento.
Caporetto, sapete, è una disfatta italiana in occasione di un attacco che il nemico monta sul nostro fronte.
Ora noi abbiamo perso a Caporetto anche, fra i tanti motivi, anche perché non eravamo abituati a essere attaccati.
La prima guerra mondiale l'abbiamo fatta sempre attaccando noi.
E qui c'è una logica molto precisa.
In guerra raramente le forze in campo sono pari come in una partita a scacchi,
e quindi c'è un equilibrio che soltanto poi l'abilità di uno dei due può rompere.
In guerra non è quasi mai così.
Le guerre sono asimmetriche, c'è quasi sempre uno che è più forte e uno che è più debole.
E di solito quello che è più forte attacca, e quello che è più debole cerca di difendersi.
Ora noi, il Regno d'Italia, rispetto all'impero austro-ungarico, eravamo certamente più deboli.
Ieri sera ho citato delle cifre.
Benché l'Austria-Ungheria fosse la più debole delle grandi potenze europee, a parte noi,
per ogni tonnellata d'acciaio che l'Italia produceva, l'Austria-Ungheria ne produceva tre.
La Germania ne produceva 19, lasciamo perdere.
Ma comunque l'Austria-Ungheria era più forte, più popolosa, più industrializzata di noi.
Però noi entriamo in guerra nel maggio del 1915, in un momento in cui l'Austria è già in guerra da dieci mesi,
e in quei dieci mesi ha subito delle batoste spaventose.
L'Austria è il paese che ha scatenato la guerra, aggredendo la Serbia per punirla delle sue complicità nell'attentato di Sarajevo.
Le altre potenze sono entrate in guerra una dopo l'altra.
L'Austria si trova in guerra contro la Serbia, nei Balcani, e contro la Russia, in Galizia, in Polonia.
E in quei primi dieci mesi di guerra l'Austria subisce delle sconfitte spaventose,
sia contro i serbi nei Balcani, sia soprattutto contro i russi in Galizia.
L'esercito austriaco d'anteguerra è quasi annientato.
La maggioranza degli ufficiali austriaci in servizio all'inizio della guerra cadono o sono fatti prigionieri o feriti in quei primi dieci mesi di guerra.
Nessuno può dare delle cifre precise sulle perdite.
Ogni volta che vedete per la prima guerra mondiale delle cifre precise, precise, sappiate che non sono vere.
Nessuno sa veramente in dettaglio quanti morti, quanti feriti, quanta gente sparita per sempre.
Nemmeno la burocrazia europea di quell'epoca, che era una burocrazia pignola, attentissima, peggio della nostra attuale.
Era una burocrazia capace di contare quante galline c'erano nel pollaio di un contadino,
ma nemmeno la burocrazia di allora riusciva a tenere il conto degli uomini buttati nella fornace e che sparivano.
Detto questo, a occhio e croce, l'esercito austriaco, nei primi dieci mesi di guerra, ha perso un milione di uomini.
Quando si parla di perdite non si intendono morti, perdite vuole sempre dire i morti, i feriti, i prigionieri.
I morti sono una minoranza, però quell'esercito ha dovuto cancellare dai suoi ruolini un milione di uomini.
E sta ancora combattendo su due fronti.
E noi entriamo in guerra e gli apriamo un terzo fronte.
Perciò noi siamo obiettivamente più forti in quel momento.
Il grosso delle forze austriache sono e rimarranno sempre, fino al 1918, fino alla rivoluzione russa,
sono e rimarranno sul fronte orientale e nei Balcani contro di noi, gli austriaci, all'inizio non hanno niente.
E anche dopo faranno sempre un'enorme fatica per mettere in trincea quel minimo di uomini indispensabile
per provare a difendersi.
Noi abbiamo più uomini, più cannoni, più munizioni, più aeroplani, più da mangiare.
Perciò attacchiamo noi.
Noi entriamo nella prima guerra mondiale con la convinzione che entrando noi crolla tutto.
L'Austria è già a lumicino combattendo su due fronti, come fa a resistere?
Entriamo noi, crolla.
Entro qualche mese, anzi, entro qualche settimana si va a Trieste,
entro qualche mese a Zagabria, a Ljubljana, fine anno a Vienna.
E si mette fine alla prima guerra mondiale.
E invece, come sapete, non va così.
Ma non perché noi non abbiamo attaccato.
Noi attacchiamo.
Sapete com'è la linea del fronte?
Il confine è ininterrotto, ma ci sono solo due zone dove si può combattere,
perché il resto è alta montagna.
E in alta montagna si combatte pro forma,
ma si fanno belle imprese con gli alpini,
ma in realtà la guerra vera si fa dove arrivano le strade, le ferrovie,
dove puoi portare le centinaia di migliaia di uomini, le migliaia di cannoni.
La guerra vera si può fare solo in Trentino e davanti a Trieste.
E il nostro comando supremo, Cadorna,
decide fin dall'inizio che anche il Trentino è troppo stretto,
non c'è abbastanza spazio per spingere.
Perciò in Trentino si starà fermi,
si attacca verso Trieste.
Attaccare verso Trieste vuol dire attaccare sul Lisonzo,
che grosso modo corre più o meno lungo il vecchio confine.
Si tratta di passare Lisonzo,
di prendere un po' di montagne,
di prendere l'altipiano del Carso,
e dietro il Carso c'è Trieste.
E lì a pochi chilometri sembra facilissimo.
Come sapete non ci arriveremo mai,
se non alla fine della guerra.
Ma non perché non ci abbiamo provato.
Cadorna, Caporetto sarà il 24 ottobre 1917.
In quei due anni e mezzo fino a Caporetto,
Cadorna attacca continuamente sul Lisonzo.
Undici battaglie del Lisonzo.
La dodicesima sarà Caporetto.
Il fatto stesso che si chiamano tutte battaglie del Lisonzo
vi dimostra che non si andava tanto avanti.
si continua a spingere lì.
Ogni tanto si va un po' avanti,
si prende un chilometro, due chilometri,
tre chilometri di terreno,
una montagnola, un'altra.
Le grandi vittorie,
una grande vittoria nel 16,
si prende Gorizia.
Dopo averci provato per un anno e mezzo,
finalmente si prende Gorizia.
Pochi chilometri,
poi si ricomincia a battere.
Però attacchiamo sempre noi.
Prima di Caporetto,
gli austriaci attaccano sul nostro fronte
una sola volta
contro undici offensive di Cadorna sull'Lisonzo.
Attaccano una sola volta
nella primavera del 16,
in Trentino.
Attaccano perché il comandante austriaco,
il felmaresciallo Conrad,
ci tiene talmente tanto
a provare,
a vendicarsi
di quei traditori di italiani
che erano nostri alleati
nella triplice alleanza
e invece poi sono entrati in guerra
contro di noi.
Che anche se l'impero è all'umicino,
Conrad riesce a convincere la politica,
a dargli le risorse,
i mezzi, i cannoni, gli uomini
per tentare un attacco.
Una volta ci provano.
E quell'offensiva nel Trentino,
appunto del maggio del 16,
che i giornali battezzano subito
la spedizione punitiva,
la strafexpedizione,
per punire, appunto,
i traditori italiani.
E il nostro comando
si aspetta talmente poco
che quei pezzenti di austriaci
possano attaccarci
che viene preso
completamente di sorpresa.
Per cui gli austriaci
nel maggio del 16,
nel Trentino,
sfondano,
travolgono le nostre linee,
vengono giù,
poi vengono fermati
con uno sforzo enorme
di tutto l'esercito,
dei comandi
che riescono a gestire bene la cosa
e naturalmente delle truppe
che combattono
come non avevamo mai combattuto prima.
In quei posti che adesso
danno i nomi alle nostre strade
e alle nostre piazze,
il Pasubbio,
l'altipiano d'Asiago,
Passobuole,
lì vengono fermati
per un pelo,
perché per un pelo
arrivavano a Vicenza.
Dopodiché,
l'unica volta
che hanno attaccato loro,
dopo ricominciamo
ad attaccare noi
e loro hanno speso
in quell'unico tentativo
tutto quello che avevano.
noi stiamo sempre meglio,
il sistema funziona
sempre meglio,
l'industria in Italia cresce,
gli alleati ci aiutano,
primavera 17
entrano in guerra
gli Stati Uniti,
arriva una valanga
di roba,
noi stiamo bene,
gli austriaci
stanno sempre peggio.
Anzi,
a dirla tutta,
è un aspetto
magari un po' meno conosciuto
della Prima Guerra Mondiale,
l'Austria è un impero
che sta morendo di fame,
letteralmente morendo di fame,
non ha più nessun accesso
al mare,
rimane Trieste,
ma l'Adriatico
è in mano alla nostra flotta,
quella francese,
non si passa,
non arriva niente da fuori
in Austria
e neanche in Germania,
anche in Germania
non stanno bene,
in Germania
l'inverno 16-17
è rimasto
nella memoria collettiva
dei tedeschi
come l'inverno
delle rape,
perché quello
c'era da mangiare,
cavoli e rape,
ma la Germania
è potente,
forte,
solida,
tira avanti,
l'Austria,
che è un gradino sotto,
muore di fame,
ci sono le testimonianze
degli ufficiali
che vanno in licenza
a Vienna
e dicono
santo cielo
che facce
che ha la gente,
ecco,
e i soldati
in trincea
non hanno da mangiare,
e noi attacchiamo
e gli austriaci
resistono
nonostante tutto,
ecco,
il fatto che resistano
così ostinatamente
merita di essere spiegato,
ci sono almeno
due motivi,
uno
è che in realtà
la prima guerra mondiale
è una guerra
che favorisce i difensori,
sapete,
non è sempre la stessa cosa,
dipende da che armi ci sono,
ci sono epoche
in cui gli armamenti
disponibili
aiutano gli attaccanti,
pensate alla seconda guerra mondiale
con i carri armati
che vanno avanti
e sfondano tutto,
nella prima guerra mondiale
è il contrario,
le armi nuove
cosa sono?
la mitragliatrice
e la mitragliatrice
raddoppia la capacità
dei difensori
in una trincea,
tu hai cento fucili
a difendere
duecento metri di fronte
ma se hai anche
una mitragliatrice
è come se ne avessi
il doppio,
le novità tecnologiche
sono la mitragliatrice,
il filo spinato,
la trincea,
nella prima guerra mondiale
attaccare
vuol dire attaccare
un nemico
che sta magari
a tre o quattrocento metri
più in là,
però è in trincea,
non li vedi neanche,
tu anche sei in trincea,
quando è ora
di attaccare
esci,
devi attraversare
di corsa
quei tre,
quattrocento,
cinquecento metri
che però
sono pieni
di filo spinato
e intanto
gli altri
ti sparano.
Allora
nella prima guerra mondiale
tutte le offensive
costano carissime,
costano una marea
di morti
e di feriti
e falliscono
o ottengono
minimi risultati
ed è così
anche sul nostro fronte,
però c'è anche
un'altra motivazione
ed è che
gli austriaci
a questa guerra
contro gli italiani
ci credono.
Della guerra
contro i russi
agli ufficiali austriaci
importa tutto sommato
poco,
non c'è nessun odio
particolare
nei loro confronti
e si sta combattendo
nelle province
più povere
dell'impero,
la Galizia,
di cui in realtà
non importa niente
a nessuno,
gli ufficiali austriaci
scherzano,
chi perde la guerra
si prende la Galizia,
ma sul nostro fronte
è un'altra cosa,
lì c'è Trento,
c'è Trieste soprattutto,
l'unico porto vero
dell'impero
e lì
c'è un'altra questione,
c'è l'imperialismo italiano
che si vuole affermare,
che chiaramente
ha dichiarato
fin dallo scoppio
della guerra
che noi vogliamo
andare al Brennero
e vogliamo l'Istria,
la Dalmazia,
vogliamo allargarci
nei Balcani
e le popolazioni locali
questo lo sanno.
Nel Trentino
noi attacchiamo
poco o niente
ma se avessimo attaccato
ci trovavamo di fronte
dei reggimenti
di Kaiser Jäger
tirolesi
reclutati sul posto
che sapevano benissimo
che stavano combattendo
per difendere
le loro case
e sul Lisonzo
i reparti che resistono,
sapete l'esercito austriaco
è un esercito
dove si parla
in dieci lingue
ma sul Lisonzo
ci sono reparti sloveni,
croati
i quali
anche loro
stanno combattendo
perché dal loro punto di vista
Gorizia è una città loro,
Trieste è una città loro,
l'Istria è loro
e non vogliono
che gli italiani
vengano di nuovo
a comandare a casa loro
come hanno fatto
per tanti secoli
al tempo dei veneziani
quindi l'esercito austriaco
morendo di fame
inferiore di numero
resiste disperatamente
e noi si va avanti
un pezzettino per volta
però comunque
si va avanti
un pochino
e nell'agosto
del 17
l'undicesima battaglia
del Lisonzo
è una vittoria
per i criteri di allora
una netta vittoria
andiamo avanti
sull'altipiano
della Bainsizza
oltre Gorizia
andiamo avanti
per 8-10 chilometri
che per i criteri
della prima guerra mondiale
sembra una cosa enorme
è l'agosto del 17
caporetto
sarà il 24 ottobre
in quell'agosto del 17
noi andiamo avanti
sulla Bainsizza
poi lentamente
come sempre
l'offensiva
si esaurisce
le perdite
sono troppe
gli austriaci
riescono ancora
una volta
a tappare
il buco
ma per l'ultima volta
il comando austriaco
si rende conto
di aver finito
tutto
non c'è più
un uomo
da aggiungere
perciò
al comando austriaco
mentre l'offensiva italiana
dell'agosto
è ancora in corso
al comando austriaco
ci si dice
stavolta
teniamo ancora
ma se Cadorna
attacca un'altra volta
quest'autunno
è finita
sfondano
gli italiani
vanno a Trieste
e se gli italiani
l'impero crolla
e c'è troppo
valore simbolico
oltre che economico
perciò
i comandanti austriaci
si dicono
che bisogna
assolutamente
fare qualcosa
non possiamo
stare fermi
a aspettare
che Cadorna
attacchi un'altra volta
e Testardo
com'è
attaccherà
di sicuro
quest'autunno
sembra che gli italiani
non le finiscano mai
le munizioni
gli uomini
perciò
il comando austriaco
si dice
dobbiamo fare qualcosa
noi
dobbiamo attaccare noi
li dobbiamo
ributtare
almeno un po'
indietro
dobbiamo guadagnare
un po' di spazio
un po' di respiro
dobbiamo attaccare noi
ma non hanno
assolutamente
i mezzi
per farlo
voi capite
in quelle condizioni
con la trincea
la mitragliatrice
il filo spinato
poi parleremo
dei cannoni
e degli aerei
in quelle condizioni
per attaccare tu
bisogna che almeno
nel punto
che hai scelto
per attaccare
tu sia più forte
almeno in un punto
devi essere il doppio
il triplo
altrimenti non passerai mai
e gli austriaci
non hanno assolutamente
i mezzi
per farlo
però hanno il fratello
maggiore
i tedeschi
la Germania
del Reich
come dicevano loro
del secondo Reich
la Germania
del Kaiser Guglielmo
hanno gli alleati
e decidono
con grande fatica
e imbarazzo
di andare
a chiedere aiuto
agli alleati
ai tedeschi
con grande fatica
e imbarazzo
uno si immagina
a volte ingenuamente
che in guerra
gli alleati
si vogliano bene
fra loro
e siano contenti
di aiutarsi
come in politica
non è vero niente
gli alleati
si odiano
sono costretti
a stare insieme
ma hanno interessi
divergenti
e sarebbero contenti
di vedere l'altro
che crolla
purché loro
non fossero coinvolti
per di più
l'alleanza
con i tedeschi
è una cosa dura
da mandare giù
i tedeschi
sono moderni
forti
ricchi
potenti
e guardano gli austriaci
dall'alto in basso
questa è una delle cose
più imbarazzanti
a dire la verità
perché
perché noi
per gli austriaci
siamo allo stesso livello
capite
siamo due paesi
sospesi
fra la modernità
e l'arretratezza
sia noi
sia l'Austria
abbiamo un'industria
un'industria pesante
noi abbiamo
Torino
Milano
Genova
loro hanno
Vienna
Praga
Budapest
però poi
entrambi i paesi
hanno un grande
entroterra contadino
poverissimo
arretrato
tassi di analfabetismo
molto più alti
rispetto alla Francia
alla Germania
all'Inghilterra
siamo paesi
mezzo moderni
e mezzo arretrati
le due più deboli
fra le grandi potenze
per noi
l'esercito austriaco
è un avversario
formidabile
abbiamo battuto
il naso
undici volte
nonostante tutto
e anche noi
per gli austriaci
siamo un avversario
formidabile
gli austriaci
hanno un gran rispetto
dell'esercito italiano
della sua artiglieria
dell'ostinazione
di Cadorna
che continua
a attaccare
siamo allo stesso livello
invece i tedeschi
quando guardano
gli austriaci
dicono
e lo dicono
e lo scrivono
se no non potrei
raccontarvelo
i generali tedeschi
dell'esercito austriaco
pensano
questi primitivi
balcanici
pasticcioni
arretrati
fatalisti
come dei turchi
non sanno
organizzare niente
sono sempre lì
che dicono
vabbè speriamo
che vada bene
e gli austriaci
lo sanno
che i tedeschi
pensano questo
di loro
e gli austriaci
dei tedeschi
pensano
questi padri eterni
sanno tutto loro
padroni del mondo
che odio
dover andare
d'accordo con loro
peggio ancora
dover andare
col cappello in mano
a chiedere
per piacere
dateci una mano
però alla fine
di agosto
gli austriaci
sono talmente
mal ridotti
che vanno
a chiedere aiuto
ai tedeschi
l'altra cosa
imbarazzante
è la reazione
dei generali tedeschi
perché i generali tedeschi
agli austriaci
rispondono
ma perché dovremmo
sprecare delle risorse
per un fronte
insignificante
come quello italiano
la guerra in Italia
non ha nessuna importanza
vada come vada
noi abbiamo cose
più importanti
da fare
gli austriaci
insistono
forse non avete capito
guardate che se
quelli prendono
Trieste
nell'impero
scoppia la rivoluzione
crolla tutto
a questo punto
i tedeschi
ci ragionano un po'
e il comandante
in capo
dell'esercito tedesco
il Feldmaresciallo
von Hindenburg
che è molto vecchio
si ricorda
che quando lui
era bambino
un'altra grande guerra
la guerra di Crimea
era finita
per la caduta
di un porto
Sebastopoli
gli alleati
avevano preso
Sebastopoli
la Russia
si era arresa
e Hindenburg
dice
vabbè abbiamo capito
con l'Austria
rischia di succedere
la stessa cosa
Trieste
è troppo importante
dobbiamo aiutarli
detto fra parentesi
giusto per il piacere
di affrescare
il personaggio
con due pennellate
il Feldmaresciallo
von Hindenburg
era già molto vecchio
abbastanza vecchio
da ricordarsi
la guerra di Crimea
vivrà ancora
molto a lungo
nella Germania
fra le due guerre
diventerà presidente
della Repubblica
di Weimar
pur essendo
un monarchico
convinto
nostalgico
del Kaiser
ma lo fanno
presidente lo stesso
i tedeschi
e farà ancora
in tempo
nel 1934
a nominare
cancelliere del Reich
un signore
con i baffetti
che ha appena vinto
le elezioni
ma torniamo
al 1917
Hindenburg
e il suo
principale collaboratore
il grande stratega
dell'esercito tedesco
Ludendorff
si dicono
va bene
bisogna dare
una mano
a questi sciagurati austriaci
un po' di forze
sul momento
le possiamo forse
risparmiare
però bisogna vedere
se questa cosa
ha un senso
gli austriaci
sono arrivati
con un piano
hanno studiato
il fronte
e hanno visto
dove sarebbe
il punto giusto
per attaccare
qui voi dovete
immaginare
questo fronte
che lungo Lisonzo
scende dalle montagne
verso il mare
verso l'Adriatico
davanti a Trieste
tutto l'esercito italiano
è ammassato
in basso
sul mare
e sul Carso
perché vogliamo andare
a Trieste
e si attacca lì
sul Carso
dove c'è spazio
più su
è tutta montagna
non vale la pena
di ammassare
grandi forze
non ci interessa
spingere in lì
all'inizio della guerra
abbiamo spinto un po'
sì
nei primi giorni di guerra
gli alpini
hanno preso una montagna
il monte Nero
si è fatta anche una canzone
talmente c'era entusiasmo
per questa presa del monte Nero
poi
ci si è fermati
tanto lì
non si va da nessuna parte
le nostre truppe
sono tutte più giù
lì c'è un velo di truppe
giusto per tenere
la linea delle trincee
tanto che paura c'è
gli austriaci
mica ci attaccano
attacchiamo sempre noi
lì sotto il monte Nero
c'è anche un paesino
sloveno
all'epoca era un paesino sloveno
che si chiamava Kobarid
e anche adesso
è un paesino sloveno
che si chiama Kobarid
solo che il 24 maggio
i bersaglieri ci sono entrati
e gli hanno cambiato nome
si è chiamato Caporetto
dopodiché si è aperta
una scuoletta di italiano
per insegnare ai figli
dei montanari sloveni
che adesso sono
dei cittadini sudditi italiani
e noi siamo lì
e siamo lì per restare
tanto la guerra
poi la vinceremo
ma in quel settore lì
però non abbiamo quasi niente
poco
perché tanto
gli austriaci hanno visto
tutto questo
arrivano dai tedeschi
gli dicono guardate lì
lo vedete Caporetto
Caporetto
sì c'è il monte Nero davanti
pieno di alpini
ma ci sono dei passaggi
per attaccare sui lati
non andiamo a attaccare
il monte Nero
passiamo giù
nel fondo valle
se uno arriva a Caporetto
la vedete la carta geografica
si incrociano lì
le strade
le vallate
e subito lì
a sud di Caporetto
si apre una bellissima valle
che si chiama
la Val Natisone
che scende giù
tranquilla
in un attimo
sei nella pianura italiana
sei a Cividale
in due giorni
sei a Udine
dove c'è il comando supremo
di Cadorna
che agli italiani
sembra il posto più sicuro
del mondo
anche Caporetto
in realtà gli sembra
il posto più sicuro
del mondo
se si arriva lì
in un attimo
scendi in pianura
li prendi alle spalle
e gli austriaci
dicono
quando noi sfondiamo lì
Cadorna
vedrà che il grosso
del suo esercito
ammassato più a sud
rischia di essere preso
alle spalle
perciò dovrà ritirarsi
dovranno tornare
un po' indietro
gli italiani
tedeschi dicono
quindi voi vorreste
farli tornare
un pochino indietro
sì
dicono gli austriaci
almeno fino al vecchio confine
cioè quel territorio
che loro hanno preso
dopo il 24 maggio
lì sullo spartiacque
tedeschi dicono
se ci muoviamo noi
non lo facciamo
per così poco
se veniamo noi
gli italiani
li buttiamo
così indietro
che non potranno
fermarsi
finché non incontrano
almeno un grande fiume
per ripararsi dietro
qual è il primo
grande fiume
che si trova
vai vai vai vai
ecco il tagliamento
se veniamo noi
li spingiamo
almeno fino
al tagliamento
i generali austriaci
rispondono
non ci arriverete
mai
i tedeschi
dicono
vediamo
però prima
dobbiamo dare un'occhiata
non abbiamo ancora
promesso niente
dobbiamo vedere
un po' com'è davvero
questo fronte
di cui ci parlate
per cui chiamano
un generale tedesco
esperto
nella guerra
in montagna
un bavarese
il generale
Kraft von Delmenzingen
e lo mandano
a dare un'occhiata
il generale Kraft
per qualche giorno
fa il giro
delle trincee
nel settore
di Caporetto
con gli ufficiali austriaci
che gli fan vedere tutto
con un berretto austriaco
in testa
per evitare
che se lo vedono
gli italiani
si accorgano
di qualcosa
e poi telefona
e dice
è molto difficile
ma si può fare
gli italiani
hanno delle posizioni
fortissime
montagne
piene di cannoni
posizioni
che sembrano
imprendibili
però ci sono gli italiani
tutto sommato
dice il generale Kraft
secondo me
noi tedeschi
gli austriaci
no
ma noi tedeschi
ce la possiamo fare
e qui comincia
quella che
a me devo dire
è sembrata
la fase più straordinaria
di tutta questa storia
cioè
la pianificazione
di una offensiva
da parte
dello stato maggiore
tedesco
perché va bene
tu hai preso
la decisione politica
voi capite
in guerra
ti vengono tante belle idee
vorresti fare
un sacco di belle cose
non puoi fare
quasi niente
perché i mezzi
sono quelli che sono
se fai una cosa
non ne fai altre
perciò la decisione
di allocare
delle risorse
al fronte italiano
è una decisione politica
presa al massimo livello
il comando supremo
il Kaiser
va bene
lo facciamo
cosa gli diamo
agli austriaci
sei divisioni
è quello che possiamo
risparmiare
sei divisioni
vuol dire
centocinquantamila uomini
a occhio croce
gli austriaci dicono
non potreste darcene otto
i tedeschi dicono
no
ne abbiamo sei
vedrete che basteranno
va bene
a questo punto
l'hai detto
e hai anche individuato
le sei divisioni
che in quel momento
sono a riposo
e che sono anche
magari più esperte
nella guerra in montagna
quindi hai già deciso
quali divisioni
andranno lì
dopodiché cosa si fa
e da Berlino
telefonano a un generale
bravo
che se ne sta in Austria
in Francia
a comandare un'armata
un prussiano
il generale von Bellow
gli dicono
caro vieni a Berlino
che dobbiamo parlarti
il generale von Bellow
va a Berlino
all'immenso palazzone
del grande stato maggiore
che oggi non esiste più
è stato raso al suolo
dai bombardamenti americani
durante la seconda guerra mondiale
ma più o meno
allo stesso posto
c'è la cancelleria
della Merkel
e al palazzo
del grande stato maggiore
che i militari tedeschi
in gergo
chiamano di grosse bude
la gran baracca
va a sentire
cosa gli vogliono dire
e gli dicono
guarda noi
abbiamo deciso
di attaccare l'Italia
per dare una mano
agli austriaci
organizzeremo
una nuova armata
sei divisioni
tu la comandi
ti abbiamo assegnato
un capo di stato maggiore
il generale Kraft von
del Menzingen
che è già stato lì a vedere
un esperto di cannoni
un esperto di aeroplani
un esperto di treni
un esperto di carburante
incontrati con loro
fateci il progetto
di questa offensiva
siamo ai primi di settembre
il generale von Bellow
dice ma entro quando
dobbiamo fare?
subito
diciamo
al più tardi
a metà ottobre
perché poi lì nevica
non hai idea
di che posti sono
due giorni dopo
il generale von Bellow
è in un albergo
di Vienna
con i suoi collaboratori
spianano le mappe
sul tavolo
e cominciano
a ragionare
dobbiamo portare lì
sei divisioni
portare lì
cosa vuol dire?
ci sono delle stazioni
le ferrovie arriva
lì vicino
neanche per idea
le stazioni più vicine
sì ci sono
delle stazioncine
Villach
Klagenfurt
Ljubljana
sono le più vicine
da lì
le truppe
una volta scese
dai treni
dovranno ancora fare
una settimana
di marcia
in montagna
solo per arrivare
sulle posizioni
di partenza
due sole strade
due passi
a mille metri
salire su
scendere giù
una settimana
ci vorrà
intanto portiamole
a quelle tre stazioncine
sei divisioni
che vengono
una in Romania
una sui Carpazzi
una in Ucraina
una in Polonia
due sono in Francia
dai quattro angoli
d'Europa
bisogna portarle
in quelle tre stazioncine
in treno
ovviamente
150.000 uomini
5.000 cannoni
solo per tirare
poi i cannoni
30.000 cavalli
due milioni
di proiettili
di artiglieria
ognuno pesa
mezzo quintale
in media
e tutta questa roba
bisogna portarla
in treno
dai quattro angoli
d'Europa
a quelle tre stazioncine
nelle prossime settimane
perciò
è uno stato maggiore tedesco
ci si mette lì
e si studia
non per niente
c'è un esperto di treni
si fa
l'orario ferroviario
per questi spostamenti
sapete quanti treni
ci vogliono
per portare
tutta quella roba
in quelle tre stazioncine
di provincia
2400 treni
100.000
vagoni ferroviari
da caricare
e scaricare
e loro fanno
nel giro di qualche giorno
l'orario ferroviario
di 2400 treni
che arriveranno
a portare
tutta quella gente
tutta quella roba
in quelle tre stazioncine
e gli orari
li fanno i tedeschi
e i treni
si mettono in movimento
all'ora giusta
e cominciano
via via
ad arrivare
a scaricare
le truppe
naturalmente
gli orari
li hanno fatti i tedeschi
ma i treni
sono austriaci
quindi
cominciano subito
le grane
ogni tanto
si perde un treno
a un certo punto
anche gli austriaci
collaborano
anche loro
stanno facendo venire
usando ancora
altri treni
anche loro
truppe
cannoni
a un certo punto
telefonano gli austriaci
purtroppo
ci sono due batterie
di cannoni
super pesanti
indispensabili
per l'offensiva
non sappiamo
dove sono finite
tocca telefonare
a tutte le stazioni
dell'impero
poi erano finite
in Transilvania
tornano indietro
i tedeschi
prendono nota
mi sa che per metà ottobre
non ce la facciamo
però vabbè
intanto ci proviamo
la roba arriva
e poi
tutte queste truppe
sbarcano
in queste stazioncine
passano qualche giorno
a riposarsi
ricevono un addestramento
speciale per la guerra
in montagna
nuove armi
perché sono tedeschi
non si dimentica niente
nei preparativi
quando sono pronti
si mettono in marcia
quella famosa
settimana di marcia
in montagna
proprio l'ultima settimana
prima di scatenare
l'attacco
siccome ci sono solo
due strade
anche il movimento
sulle strade
è pianificato
come se fosse una ferrovia
lungo le strade
ci sono gli ufficiali tedeschi
con le lampade
gli orari
i battaglioni partono
a una certa ora
arrivano a una certa ora
solo in questo modo
si riesce a far arrivare
quasi tutto
naturalmente
questa è la cosa
vista dallo stato maggiore
che se ne sta
nei suoi uffici
le truppe che marciano
marciano per una settimana
in montagna
ah dimenticavo
solo di notte
tutta la marcia
viene fatta solo
di notte
perché di giorno
gli italiani volano
e non vogliamo
che vedano
quello che sta arrivando
questa marcia di notte
noi abbiamo anche
dei resoconti
dei reparti
che l'hanno fatta
una marcia spaventosa
con i soldati
che maledicono i comandi
e si chiedono
chi è il pazzo
che li ha mandati su
in alta montagna
di notte
c'è già la neve
in alto
è una marcia
terrificante
in una strada
tutta piena
di camion sfasciati
perché i camion
continuamente
escono di strada
vanno giù nel burrone
i cavalli
i muli
vanno giù nel burrone
gli uomini
vanno giù
gridano
non li sente nessuno
c'è un tale rumore
dei torrenti
della tormenta
tuttavia
arriva quasi tutto
sapete che la guerra
è quella situazione
in cui se tu devi portare
cento uomini
in un certo posto
e ne arrivano
uno è morto
è andata benissimo
perfettamente
non c'è il minimo problema
arrivano
vorrebbero attaccare
il 15 ottobre
all'inizio
poi hanno spostato
in una settimana
22 ottobre
giorno prima
gli austriaci
telefonano
non siamo ancora pronti
non sono arrivati
i proiettili a gas
per l'artiglieria
a questo punto
i tedeschi
mandano un generale
al comando austriaco
a vedere
questo torna
e dice
non vi immaginate
come lavorano quelli
hanno finito la benzina
tedeschi prestano
la benzina
agli austriaci
gli austriaci dicono
però ancora due giorni
ci vogliono
e va bene
24 ottobre
ma non oltre
il 24 ottobre
si comincia
è tutto pronto
6 divisioni tedesche
parecchie divisioni austriache
300.000 uomini
5.000 cannoni
i piani sono precisi
comincia tutto
con un bombardamento
a gas
alle 2 di notte
del 24 ottobre
4 ore di bombardamento
a gas
poi bombardamento
a esplosivo
poche ore di bombardamento
veloce veloce
e poi all'attacco
ogni reparto
ha i suoi ordini
i suoi orari
la pianificazione
vuol dire questo
che fino a quel momento
finché potevi
devi aver pensato
a tutto
poi quando comincia
la battaglia
il discorso cambia
non è che ti illudi
di pianificarla
non sai cosa succederà
un esercito vero
come quello tedesco
sa benissimo
che a quel punto
non si sa cosa succede
dobbiamo essere pronti
a tutto
la pianificazione
vale fino all'ultimo minuto
quindi sono pronti
ad attaccare
quella notte
del 24 ottobre
hanno fatto tutto
il più possibile
in segreto
gli ufficiali tedeschi
che andavano in ricognizione
in trincea
si travestivano
da austriaci
le truppe marciavano
solo di notte
hanno fatto disinformazione
trasmesso notizie
su reparti tedeschi
nel trentino
hanno fatto di tutto
per tenere segreta
questa cosa
e i nostri comandi
sanno tutto
noi sappiamo
assolutamente
tutto
ogni dettaglio
gli orari
i piani d'attacco
tutto
e sappiamo tutto
per due motivi
almeno
beh voi capite
una roba del genere
in realtà è un'illusione
tenerla nascosta
centinaia di migliaia
di uomini coinvolti
le ferrovie
dell'intero impero
come fai a tenerlo nascosto
i soldati austriaci
in trincea
per primi
anche se a loro
nessuno ha detto niente
ma sono i primi
che hanno capito tutto
sapete che è un fenomeno
che è stato riscontrato
a partire proprio
dalla prima guerra mondiale
i soldati
sanno sempre tutto
misteriosamente
ci sono i telefonisti
i cuochi
i camerieri
della mensa ufficiale
sentono
ecco
i soldati sanno tutto
i soldati austriaci
lo sanno benissimo
che presto
li manderanno
all'attacco
e che sarà
una cosa grossa
come fanno a saperlo
beh
c'è un artigliere austriaco
alla sua batteria
arriva un suo compare
vicino di casa
a Praga
e gli dice
sai che qua vicino
è arrivata una batteria
di cannoni tedeschi
dice
tedeschi ma sei sicuro
sì sì
ci ho parlato
sono tedeschi
a quel punto
la prima reazione
dei soldati austriaci
è di andare dai tedeschi
a mendicare qualcosa
da mangiare
perché i tedeschi
stanno bene
e gli austriaci
muoiono di fame
poi appunto
nel rancio
dei soldati austriaci
a un certo punto
compare
una fettina
di speck
20 grammi
di pancetta
mesi che non si vedeva
mesi di patate
cavoli e rape
arriva la pancetta
vuol dire qualcosa
dicono i soldati
poi distribuiscono
gli elmetti d'acciaio
l'austria è povera
li distribuiva
col contagocce
adesso
tutti quei treni
vagonate
di elmetti d'acciaio
alle truppe
in trincea
e poi distribuiscono
la cartolina verde
e quello è sempre
il segnale
che sta per cominciare
una battaglia
la cartolina verde
è la cartolina
in franchigia
dell'esercito austriaco
andate a vedere
si vede su internet
ci sono le immagini
volendo
è la cartolina
che i soldati
possono spedire a casa
con la posta militare
ed è fatta
per gli analfabeti
per cui c'è scritta
in nove lingue
la stessa frase
sono sano
e va tutto bene
e questo c'è scritto
in tedesco
in ungherese
in polacco
in rumeno
in italiano
in serbo croato
in ucraino
eccetera
quando la distribuiscono
i soldati sanno
qui ci mandano all'attacco
e tutto quello
che sanno i soldati austriaci
lo sanno i nostri
primo
perché ci sono
le intercettazioni telefoniche
ci sono già
degli apparecchietti
che piantati nel terreno
permettono di sentire
cosa dicono
quegli altri
al telefono
nelle trincee
100 200 300 metri
più in là
e dietro ci sono
degli uffici
con degli ufficiali
che sanno le lingue
che stanno lì
24 ore su 24
a trascrivere
tutto quello
che viene detto
al telefono
dall'altra parte
questo lo sanno tutti
lo facciamo noi
lo fanno loro
tanto che sia i nostri
sia gli austriaci
quando parlano al telefono
se possono
parlano in dialetto
nella speranza
che quelli dall'altra parte
non capiscano
di fatto
si capisce tutto
ed è dai primi di settembre
che noi intercettiamo
ufficiali austriaci
che dicono
hai saputo
che si prepara
l'offensiva
hai saputo
che vengono i tedeschi
che sarà a metà ottobre
hai saputo
che sarà a caporetto
ecco
e poi ci sono i disertori
i disertori
sono quelli
che non ne possono più
e una bella notte
decidono che loro
hanno finito
per loro la guerra
è finita
meglio cadere prigionieri
perciò
se ne vanno
di nascosto
attraversano
la terra di nessuno
e vanno ad arrendersi
i disertori
ce n'è un'infinità
nella prima guerra mondiale
tutti i giorni
continuamente
disertano soldati
capite com'è
ci sono milioni
di uomini
in trincea
che fanno una vita
da cani
che mangiano
malissimo
e che rischiano
la pelle
tutti i giorni
perciò
tutte le notti
c'è gente che scappa
disertano i nostri
e disertano gli austriaci
ma gli austriaci
disertano più
dei nostri
primo
perché i nostri
mangiano male
ma loro
crepano di fame
e secondo
perché gli austriaci
non sono tutti
sul tirolesi
o sloveni
che nonostante
tutta la guerra
contro l'Italia
l'han capita
e la fanno
perché sanno benissimo
che se si perde
verranno gli italiani
a comandare
a casa loro
come infatti
succederà puntualmente
alla fine della guerra
ma ci sono anche
nazionalità
a cui della guerra
sull'isonzo
non importa proprio niente
rumeni
cecoslovacchi
polacchi
a questi non importa niente
sono nazionalità
dove
molti in realtà
sperano di perderla
la guerra
ecco l'esercito austriaco
ha combattuto
per quattro anni
la guerra
con un esercito
dove una parte
degli ufficiali
e dei soldati
sperava di perderla
così avremo
la cecoslovacchia
indipendente
avremo la Serbia
che si unisce
alla Croazia
faremo la Jugoslavia
e perciò
un sacco di gente
anche ufficiali
che appartengono
a quelle nazionalità
disertano
negli ultimi giorni
prima di Caporetto
arrivano ufficiali
austriaci
di nazionalità
rumena
polacca
cieca
e arrivano
con gli ordini
dei loro reparti
a che ora
comincia il bombardamento
comincia l'attacco
i nostri
sanno tutto
tant'è vero
che da due giorni
è arrivato
a tutti i reparti
l'ordine
la notte
del 24 ottobre
arriva l'attacco
comincia alle due
col bombardamento
a gas
perciò
all'una e mezza
tutte le truppe
sveglie
e con la maschera
antigas addosso
e Cadorna
che all'inizio
non ci credeva
tanto a questa storia
che volevano
attaccarci
perché gli sembrava
così folle
sono così deboli
gli austriaci
va bene
vengono i tedeschi
ma che sarà mai
noi non l'abbiamo
mai sperimentati
noi ci illudiamo
a quel punto
di essere così forti
noi
che i tedeschi
non ci faranno
nessuna differenza
i nostri generali
lo dicono
se lo dicono
fra loro
e lo dicono
alle truppe
ragazzi
verranno i tedeschi
va bene
non crederete mica
che sia meglio
degli austriaci
verranno i tedeschi
benissimo
faremo dei nuovi
prigionieri
che non avevamo ancora
e li manderemo
a Milano
a farli vedere
alla gente
i prigionieri tedeschi
e poi Cadorna
comunque si dice
ma figurati
se questi attaccano
a ottobre
dopo metà ottobre
nevica già
Cadorna
fino agli ultimi giorni
nonostante
i rapporti
che arrivano
e che dicono
tutte le cose
che vi ho raccontato
Cadorna
continua a crederci
solo a metà
ancora negli ultimi giorni
lo sentono
degli ufficiali
che dice
però
comunque
Cadorna
è un professionista
poi se avremo tempo
parleremo un po' di lui
ma non avremo tempo
ma insomma
è un professionista
pieno di difetti
caratteriali
con delle arretratezze
ma anche
con delle modernità
sue
è un uomo intelligente
un uomo di prima qualità
in realtà
Cadorna
anche se ci crede poco
il suo mestiere lo fa
attaccheranno in quel settore
di Caporetto
e noi mettiamoci più truppe
ce ne erano poche
è vero all'inizio
ma quando scatta l'attacco
noi ne abbiamo
molte di più
di truppe
perché Cadorna
ha preso
un'infinità di brigate
che stavano a riposo
e le ha trasferite
in quel settore lì
perciò Cadorna
è tranquillo
si romperanno i denti
e invece come sapete
succede tutto il contrario
i tedeschi sfondano
dove attaccano gli austriaci
quasi dappertutto
li fermiamo
ma dove attaccano i tedeschi
passano come nel burro
le nostre linee
davanti ai tedeschi
crollano
le riserve ammassate dietro
si spappolano
nel giro di due giorni
è chiaro
che questi scenderanno
in pianura
nel giro di tre giorni
Cadorna deve evacuare Udine
e trasferire
il comando supremo
a Padova
nel giro di tre giorni
Cadorna deve dare ordine
all'intero esercito
di ritirarsi
è la decisione
più difficile
della sua vita
chiaramente
però la deve prendere
perché se restiamo
dove siamo
sul carso
questi ci prendono
alle spalle
allora sì che è finita
bisogna salvare
l'esercito
già quest'ordine
di ritirarsi
noi facciamo fatica
a immaginare
cosa ha voluto dire
è uno shock
da cui l'esercito italiano
per un momento
non riesce a riprendersi
capite cosa vuol dire
ritirarsi
ritirarsi vuol dire
i tedeschi
avevano calcolato giusto
ritirarsi fino al tagliamento
perché se cominciamo
a andare indietro
con delle truppe
che si ritirano
inseguite dal nemico
vittorioso
e non è che ti fermi
dove vuoi
fai dietro fronte
combatti
prima di che
un esercito
che si sta ritirando
possa di nuovo
schierarsi
e trovare il coraggio
di combattere
devi avere
un fortissimo appoggio
nel terreno
ci vuole un grande fiume
niente da fare
quindi l'ordine di ritirata
dato il terzo giorno
da Cadorna
è ritirata
al tagliamento
questo vuol dire
che l'esercito italiano
abbandona
tutto il terreno
che ha conquistato
in due anni e mezzo
di guerra
e che è costato
mezzo milione
di morti
parlo proprio
stavolta
niente
abbandoniamo tutto
non solo
torniamo ancora più indietro
in Italia
io ho trovato
il diario
di un ufficiale
che non era coinvolto
nella zona di Caporetto
perché l'attacco a Caporetto
coinvolge solo
una parte abbastanza piccola
del nostro esercito
il grosso
è più giù
sul carso
non sanno niente
arriva all'improvviso
un collega
e dice
non dirlo a nessuno
ma sembra che ci sia
l'ordine di ritirarsi
oggi pomeriggio
si parte
dice ritirarsi
ma fin dove
non è che torniamo
fino all'isonzo
che sembrava già
una cosa
dice no no
ritirata al tagliamento
e l'ufficiale
dice al collega
ma il tagliamento
è in Italia
e ci sono 100 chilometri
diventi pazzo
ecco
il grosso
dell'esercito italiano
riceve quest'ordine
come un fulmine
a Celsereno
un ordine incomprensibile
però bisogna ritirarsi
e quasi subito
si vede
che ci si ritira
perché il nemico
ha sfondato
e sta arrivando
allora la battaglia
di Caporetto
è qualche giorno
un giorno o due
di battaglia
su quelle posizioni
che vengono sfondate
e poi sono due settimane
di ritirata
inseguiti dal nemico
fermandosi a combattere
ogni volta che si può
e perdendo
quasi sempre
questi scontri
e poi di nuovo
ritirarsi
ed è lì che
una battaglia perduta
diventa una
catastrofe nazionale
Caporetto
io adesso provo
a darvi un'idea
dell'entità
della catastrofe
di Caporetto
non è perché
abbiamo perduto
40.000 morti
e feriti
perché 40.000
morti e feriti
li perdevamo
in una qualunque
delle nostre offensive
sull'isonzo
era una cosa
normalissima
i comandi
non facevano
né caldo
né freddo
però abbiamo perso
300.000 prigionieri
nel corso
della ritirata
man mano
quegli altri arrivano
e catturano
gente che non è riuscita
a scappare
abbastanza in fretta
alla fine
avranno catturato
300.000 prigionieri
ora 300.000 prigionieri
è già un'altra cifra
c'è uno zero
in più
l'uno per cento
della popolazione italiana
un italiano
su cento
è caduto
prigioniero
a Caporetto
tutto compreso
donne
bambini
ecco
uno su cento
di questi 300.000 prigionieri
oltretutto
molti non torneranno
a casa
perché la prigionia
nella prima guerra mondiale
è un'esperienza
spaventosa
specialmente
la prigionia
in un paese
che sta morendo
di fame
come l'Austria
i lager
che chiamano già così
è uno dei più famosi
è un lager
che sarà poi
ancora più famoso
col nazismo
Mauthausen
i lager
sono già dei posti
dove si muore
anche se non ci sono
le SS
non ci sono le camera gas
nessuno vuole
che i prigionieri muoiano
però non c'è niente
da mangiare
muoiono di fame
i civili austriaci
figuratevi cosa c'è
per i prigionieri italiani
e quindi i prigionieri italiani
muoiono di fame
di tifo
di spagnola
nel 18
non solo
il nostro esercito
ha perso
40.000 morti e feriti
e pazienza
300.000 prigionieri
e quella è già una bella botta
ma il fatto è che
di quel milione di uomini
che si stanno ritirando
più di metà
non sono più soldati
sono sbandati
sbandati è un termine
che entra nell'uso
dei giornalisti
in quel momento
non si parla d'altro
gli sbandati
sono i soldati
che si stanno ritirando
verso casa
e hanno buttato via
il fucile
e non ubbidiscono più
agli ufficiali
camminano
perché l'idea è
torniamo a casa
la guerra è finita
l'abbiamo persa
e chi se ne frega
se l'abbiamo persa
l'importante è che è finita
la maggioranza
dei soldati italiani
in quelle settimane
è convinta
che la guerra è finita
e molti
osservatori
giornalisti
ufficiali
politici
notano
questi sono quasi contenti
sono spensierati
tranquilli
è andata male
pazienza
però si torna a casa
cantano
addio mia bella
addio
la pace
la faccio io
quando sono un po'
incattiviti
passando vicino
agli ufficiali
li guardano in faccia
gli dicono
è finita la camorra
perché per i soldati
in trincea
la guerra è stato
quello
la camorra
il cuciniere
che dava le razioni
più abbondanti
ai suoi amici
gli imboscati
che non rischiavano
mai la pelle
gli amici del comandante
che prende
ecco
e noi a crepare
in trincea
la camorra
i carabinieri
che mangiano meglio
degli altri
perché aiutano
i generali
a fucilare la gente
la camorra
adesso è finita
quindi questo esercito
in quelle settimane
sembra che si stia sfasciando
e questo esercito
si ritira
in un
paesaggio
terrificante
dove brucia tutto
brucia tutto
perché noi
diamo fuoco
a tutto
l'ordine è
dar fuoco a tutto
per non lasciare niente
al nemico
il primo giorno
di ritirata
i nostri soldati
che in trincea
mangiavano male
scoprono
che subito dietro
la nostra previdente
burocrazia
ha allestito
degli immensi
depositi
pieni di roba
milioni di scatolette
di carne in scatola
americana
sono i nostri alleati
sono entrati in guerra
ci mandano la roba
scatolette di salmone
gli americani
producevano una marea
di salmone
i nostri soldati
in trincea
mangiavano salmone
o meglio
restavano i magazzini
ad aspettare
barilli di liquore
fiaschi di vino
uniformi nuove
biancheria
scarpe
tutto
c'è tutto
e l'ordine è
dar fuoco
a tutto
i soldati
dann fuoco a tutto
però prima entrano
si riempiono lo zaino
si riempiono la pancia
sfondano le botti di liquore
vanno in giro
con i fiaschi appesi
si ubriacano
persi
la maggior parte di loro
faranno tutta la ritirata
ubriachi
entri nei magazzini
prendi tutto
e dai fuoco
dai fuoco ai magazzini
dai fuoco ai paesi
alle ferrovie
le stazioni
le locomotive
ordini superiori
si brucia tutto
e quando sono finiti
i magazzini militari
comincia a entrare
nei negozi
nei negozi privati
nelle case
i soldati in ritirata
saccheggiano tutto
Udine
Pordenone
le cascine
le campagne
dappertutto
i soldati marciano
continuamente
con la pancia piena
per la prima volta
da tanto tempo
ubriachi
entrando a prendere
quello che vogliono
impunemente
quasi sempre
perché poi è una lotteria
la cosa più pazzesca
è che se sei molto sfortunato
invece giri l'angolo
e lì c'è un picchetto
di carabinieri
con un ufficiale impazzito
che perquisisce
quelli che passano
e se tu sei entrato
in una casa
hai trovato in un cassetto
delle calze da donna
te le sei messe in tasca
per portarle all'amorosa
te le trovano
ti sbattono al muro
e ti fucilano
ma la stragrande maggioranza
non incontra i carabinieri
e continua a marciare così
ubriachi
cantando
e non in mezzo al fuoco
che brucia tutto
dappertutto
ci sono gli immensi
parchi di buoi
che la sussistenza
ha preparato
per dar da mangiare
alla gente
adesso bisogna liquidarli
non lasciare niente
ai tedeschi
farli fuori tutti
ma non c'è mica tempo
di sparare in testa
ogni buo
no no
sono tutti chiusi
nei recinti
si cosparge di benzina
si dà fuoco
con le bestie vive
e si continua a marciare
in mezzo a tutto questo
e
in mezzo ai soldati
i civili
perché i civili
non restano a casa
a aspettare il nemico
a dire il vero
all'inizio
i prefetti
hanno avuto ordine
di affiggere
dei bellissimi manifesti
che dicevano
niente panico
la situazione
è sotto controllo
ma la gente
ha visto
che i signori
quelli che sono
ben informati
caricavano la roba
in carrozza
o in macchina
siamo sospesi
no
fra l'ottocento
e la modernità
c'è chi ha già
la fiat
e c'è chi ha ancora
la carrozza a cavalli
i signori caricavano
la roba
e andavano via
allora anche la gente
comincia a andare via
con gran fatica
pensate alla situazione
siamo a fine ottobre
i contadini
hanno i raccolti
nei magazzini
le cantine piene
il bestiame grasso
tutta la roba
pronta per l'inverno
e bisogna andare via
in tutte le famiglie
si discute
il nonno dice
no no io resto
e molti restano
e molti vanno via
mezzo milione
di profughi
che se ne vanno
lungo questa strada
verso il tagliamento
mescolati alle truppe
diluvia continuamente
questa gente
non ha niente da mangiare
marciano
molti ufficiali
io ne ho trovato più di uno
che nei loro libri
poi ricordano
la cosa che mi ha colpito
di più durante la ritirata
la contadina
scalza
a piedi
che camminava
da non so quanti giorni
inebetita
col neonato al seno
e il neonato era morto
e lei non se n'era ancora
neanche accorta
piove continuamente
per fortuna
perché quando non piove
scendono gli aerei tedeschi
a mitragliare
e queste colonne
miste
di sbandati
di soldati
che invece hanno ancora
il fucile
si fermano a combattere
quelli che obbediscono
ancora agli ordini
si fermano a combattere
sono quelli che poi
vengono fatti prigionieri
e finiscono nei lager
gli altri scappano
tutto questo
per due settimane
verso il tagliamento
prima
e i ponti
sul tagliamento
sono pochissimi
e c'è una folla
immensa
che arriva
e a un certo punto
non si va più avanti
a un certo punto
tutte le strade
sono bloccate
allora l'ordine è
via tutti i veicoli
i reparti militari
fino a quel punto
si sono portati
i loro camion
i loro cannoni
costosissimi
tirandoli a mano
certe volte
adesso non si va più avanti
l'ordine è via tutto
via tutto
nei fossi
ai lati delle strade
i cannoni
i camion
stracarichi di roba
i carretti a cavalli
ce n'è migliaia
stracarichi di roba
gli equipaggiamenti
degli ospedali
medicinali
le casse dei reggimenti
gli archivi
le scartoffie
infinite le scartoffie
tutto via
qualche giorno dopo
arriveranno i corrispondenti
dei giornali tedeschi
al seguito delle loro truppe
e scriveranno
sui loro giornali
per le strade del veneto
sono sparsi
miliardi di roba
miliardi
in un paese
poverissimo
come l'italia
butti via tutto
i camion
i carretti a cavalli
anche qui
ti fermi a staccare i cavalli
neanche per idea
li lasci lì a crepare
i tedeschi arriveranno
due o tre giorni dopo
e troveranno chilometri
e chilometri di strade
con intorno
migliaia di carretti
con attaccati i cavalli
che sono morti di fame
rosicchiando i finimenti
e si marcia in mezzo
a tutto questo
e quando c'è un cavallo morto
i soldati si fermano
e con la baionetta
tirano via un pezzo di carne
almeno c'è qualcosa da mangiare
un cavallo morto
molti dicono
anche un cavallo vivo
naturalmente
e si arriva ai ponti
sul tagliamento
e lì davvero
non si va più avanti
i ponti
sono stracarichi
di gente
militari
civili
e non si va né avanti
né indietro
e a un certo punto
dall'altra parte dei ponti
c'è un capitano del genio
con un megafono
che dice
fra mezz'ora
il ponte salta
lo facciamo saltare noi
non lasciamo mica
i tedeschi
che stanno arrivando
noi ci dobbiamo difendere
dietro il tagliamento
fra un quarto d'ora
il ponte salta
fra cinque minuti
fra due minuti
e la gente è lì
e non si va né avanti
né indietro
poi i ponti
sul tagliamento
saltano tutti
stracarichi di gente
soldati
civili
donne
bambini
saltano tutti
e dietro il tagliamento
si tira un respiro
di sollievo
forse qui ci fermiamo
poi invece
arriva la notizia
che i tedeschi
più a nord
hanno passato anche
il tagliamento
e quindi bisogna
ricominciare
andare indietro
e finalmente
ci si ferma
il piave
dietro il piave
i tedeschi
quando arrivano
sono talmente
senza fiato
talmente stanchi
di correre dietro
e combattere
e catturare prigionieri
e rimpinzarsi
perché i tedeschi
e gli austriaci
dappertutto
divorano tutto
quello che trovano
ammazzano i maiali
rimasti
se li mangiano crudi
molti contadini
raccontano al parroco
c'è un tedesco
morto in cantina
è venuto lì
ha sfondato le botti
si è ubriacato
e affogato nel vino
arrivati al piave
i tedeschi
non ce la fanno più
si fermano
noi
per il rotto
della cuffia
riusciamo a tenere
la rotta di caporetto
è finita
abbiamo perso
40.000 morti e feriti
300.000 prigionieri
gli sbandati
a questo punto
eh lì si rimedia
un po'
perché gli sbandati
si accorgono
che la guerra
non è finita
che ci sono ancora
gli ufficiali
i carabinieri
e quindi
pian piano
gli sbandati
che sono stati rinchiusi
in enormi campi
di concentramento
pian piano
vengono rimessi
in divisa
e l'esercito
pian piano
si riforma
ma quei 300.000
sono nei lager
a crepare di fame
ci sono 500.000
profughi civili
che il governo
fino alla fine
della guerra
dovrà mantenere
e che riesce
con una certa fatica
distribuendoli
in tutta Italia
ogni comune
ne prende un po'
e
poi ci sono quelli
che sono rimasti là
perché una parte
dei civili
sono rimasti alla fine
quelli che non sono riusciti
a passare il tagliamento
quelli che hanno deciso
di non scappare
un pezzo d'Italia
tutto il friuli italiano
e un pezzo di Veneto
fino al Piave
rimane per un anno
sotto occupazione nemica
cioè sotto occupazione
di un esercito
abrutito
da tre anni di guerra
che odia gli italiani
e che crepa di fame
potete immaginare
cos'è stato
quell'anno di occupazione
i tassi di mortalità
della popolazione
rimasta sul posto
sono pazzeschi
tra la fame
le malattie
gli stupri
abbiamo molti diari
dei parroci
che raccontano
quello che succede
nei loro paesi
con i tedeschi
e gli austriaci
che portano via
tutto quello
che c'è da mangiare
tutto
le campane dei campanili
tirate giù
per fare cannoni
e insomma
in questo senso
come vi dicevo
che Caporetto
non è soltanto
una battaglia perduta
ma è una tragedia nazionale
è una catastrofe nazionale
ed è una catastrofe nazionale
che lascia
molte cicatrici
difficili da chiudere
ecco concludiamo con questo
come in ogni catastrofe nazionale
ovviamente
si scatena subito
la caccia al colpevole
di chi è la colpa
c'è la testimonianza
di un prete
amico del comando supremo
che insieme
con il famoso padre gemelli
che poi sarà
il fondatore della cattolica
e una macchina
carica di suore
stava scappando
da Udine
sede del comando supremo
sono in strada
in mezzo ai profughi
in mezzo agli sbandati
in mezzo a questa folla
che a piedi
va nella stessa direzione
della macchina
coperto di fango
vedono un deputato
il deputato di Tolmezzo
onorevole Gortani
Tolmezzo è in quella zona
cadrà in mano al nemico
in quei giorni
il deputato di Tolmezzo
riconoscendo questi preti
influenti
amici del comando supremo
sulla macchina
a terra
coperto di fango
gli grida
adesso lo fucileremo
il vostro Cadorna
quindi da un lato
ci sono questi umori
è colpa dei generali
bisogna capire
gli sbagli che hanno fatto
licenziare
punire
l'umore nel paese
è quello
un capitano
il capitano
Marpicati
che poi sarà
un importante
gerarca fascista
a quell'epoca
uno studente universitario
era in licenza
da Firenze
torna al fronte
poi la prossima volta
che torna a casa
in licenza
dopo Caporetto
la mamma
gli dice
ma è davvero
un esercito
così schifoso
il nostro
sui giornali
nei dibattiti
parlamentari
i discorsi sono
credevamo
di avere
un grande esercito
e dei grandi generali
in questo clima
di sfiducia generalizzata
appunto
che colpe hanno
i generali
vogliamo saperlo
è stata una grande
tragedia nazionale
cosa si fa in Italia
quando c'è una grande
tragedia nazionale
si nomina
una commissione
parlamentare
di inchiesta
e la commissione
parlamentare di inchiesta
fa il suo lavoro
e inchioda
molti generali
alle loro responsabilità
Cadorna
ha fatto degli sbagli
enormi
altri anche
siccome so
che qualcuno
di voi
ha questa curiosità
perché c'è sempre
qualcuno che ci pensa
e vi dirò
sì è vero
anche Badoglio
aveva delle responsabilità
grosse
e la commissione
di inchiesta
decide su di lui
di lasciar perdere
perché Badoglio
ha fatto carriera
è un uomo indispensabile
è meglio non toccarlo
non c'è niente
di molto misterioso segreto
sono cose
che succedono
tutti i giorni
naturalmente
però il punto
è che i generali
non ci stanno
a dire
sì è colpa nostra
i generali
non ci stanno affatto
e Cadorna
il giorno stesso
in cui ha dato
l'ordine di ritirata
sapendo benissimo
che era l'ordine
più pazzesco
della sua vita
e non volendo
prendersi lui
la colpa
ha pubblicato
un bollettino
del comando supremo
in cui diceva
che lui
era costretto
a dare l'ordine
di ritirata
per colpa
di reparti
dell'esercito
non tutti
e dice
di reparti
dell'esercito
che sono scappati
vigliacamente
o si sono arresi
vergognosamente
senza combattere
questa cosa
non è successa mai
in quei termini
anche se in realtà
lo sfacelo
dell'esercito
a Caporetto
è stato immenso
ma in quei termini
non è mai successo
davvero
ma il mondo
legge il bollettino
di Cadorna
a dire il vero
il governo a Roma
quando vede
questo bollettino
si mette le mani
nei capelli
capite cosa vuol dire
il nostro comandante supremo
che accusa di viltà
i nostri soldati
non si può
il bollettino
viene censurato
ma intanto
è stato già
trasmesso all'estero
e tutto il mondo
quindi si ricorderà
se lo ricordano
ancora adesso
gli appassionati
di storia
della prima guerra mondiale
in America
in Inghilterra
in Australia
se uno gli dice
Caporetto
si dica
ah sì
quel posto
dove quei vigliacchi
degli italiani
sono scappati
quella lì
è una cicatrice
non più chiusa
ma soprattutto
il problema
è che
i militari
messi sotto accusa
si convincono
che appunto
la colpa è di tutti
tranne loro
è colpa dei soldati
che sono vigliacchi
ma i soldati
sono vigliacchi
perché il paese
è marcio
il paese è marcio
perché è pieno
di rossi
di socialisti
che fanno propaganda
contro la guerra
tutto questo marciume
pacifista
i deputati socialisti
che parlano in parlamento
dicendo la guerra
deve finire
che vergogna
i generali
si convincono
che il paese
è marcio
che ha bisogno
di una bel repulisti
ecco diciamo
e che è colpa
dei politicanti
della politica liberale
del parlamento
la cosa è degenerata
fino a quel punto
perciò Caporetto
è anche il momento
in cui una parte
della classe dirigente italiana
i militari
si convincono
che il sistema
è marcio
che la democrazia
parlamentare
non funziona
che il popolo italiano
ci sono parecchie lettere
di ufficiali
in quel periodo
che dicono
mi spiace dirlo
ma il popolo italiano
ha bisogno
di cent'anni
di bastone
e come sapete
il bastone arriverà
anche se non durerà
cent'anni
ma è quello
il momento
in cui molti militari
e molti intellettuali
di destra
si convincono
che l'Italia
deve cambiare strada
e quando cambia strada
effettivamente
quella gente lì
si convincerà
che ah finalmente
chiudo con questo
il generale Cadorna
nel dopoguerra
si scambia
delle lettere
col generale
Kraft von Delmenzingen
cosa meravigliosa
è questa
che alla fine della guerra
i militari nemici
i generali nemici
cominciano a chiacchierare
da bravi amici
e si raccontano le cose
e Cadorna
nel 1925
al generale
Kraft von Delmenzingen
scrive
il disastro
di Caporetto
non sarebbe
stato possibile
se in Italia
ci fosse già stato
il forte governo
attuale
nel 1925
e Mussolini
all'indomani
del delitto
Matteotti
e Mussolini
che ha appena fatto
le leggi fascistissime
e ha trasformato
definitivamente
il suo governo
in dittatura
Cadorna
applaude
magari avessimo
già avuto
Mussolini
nel 1917
e questa
appunto
è un'altra cicatrice
che non saprei dire
se sia in qualche misura
ancora aperta adesso
ma certamente
in quegli anni
del dopoguerra
in Italia
delle conseguenze
le ha avute
grazie